hi my name is Jill Turner I'm a senior
at stammers high school and Belmar New
Jersey I'm in an honor to the class I
have a question for you since the
universe is constantly expanding do you
think that we would be able to have
people another planet earth becomes
overpopulated we look forward to your
response so Jill is asking about whether
there are possibilities of people on
other planets and how that relates to
the expanding universe well from the
expanding universe we just know that the
universe is very large and that there
are many places that people could in
principle live on the other hand we also
know because the universe is very large
that it's very hard to go from one star
to another and we don't have any way
that we thought of that's a serious
possibility for interstellar travel so
that means we have to just look at the
planets that are here in our own solar
system they're not very far away but
they're still hard to get to we've been
to the moon which is pretty close by we
have not yet put a human being on Mars
which is the next best place to get to
and so it's really hard so I think the
short answer is although the universe is
large and there are many places where
people could in principle live that is
so large that we can't get there from
here so that means we're not going to
have a solution for over population on
this planet by going someplace else so
I'm sorry to disappoint you about that
this is a really hard problem